yeah hi
um it's really really crowded so I
didn't expect that much interest in that
topic
um yeah my name is Tobias
um as you said I'm a freelancer in MLP
and machine learning
um
and yeah welcome to my really
opinionated talk on
NLP baselines and how to get started
with baselines and MLP and then probably
some things that you can
build on top of these bass lines briefly
so it's really opinionated and let's
just jump right into the agenda
so first thing is like give you a short
introduction to build measure learn
framework the general idea which most of
you are probably at least intuitively
familiar with
um and then from there kind of derive
what makes a good Baseline at least to
me it's the opinionated part
um
then we're going to look at some
examples I'm kind of
playground use case so to say
um and then sprinkle in I mean it's a
bit at the end but like sprinkling some
weekend transfer learning ideas that you
can
mix in with these bass lines and move on
from to the space lines
[Music]
yeah the large disclaimer that probably
you in the back cannot read
but
um of course you might disagree with
some of the things I say there are a lot
of different situations right a lot of
different applications
and there's of course no one size
fits-all approach
so I hope at least the first half of the
talk will also apply to General machine
learning
um ideas
um
yeah and some of the NLP things of
course won't apply to all NLP problems
you might encounter but it might give
you some ideas so the general guideline
is like it's my opinion if something
sounds useful to you just pick it up and
use it and if you do NLP probably think
about some of the things I say if it
makes sense at some point right
so yeah let's just start right in
so what's the framework the build
measure learn framework
which is commonly considered like a
framework for how to come up with
prototypes or minimal viable products in
building something
um it's usually in three or four steps
so I like to to include a iterate step
because I think it's like important to
think about that you come back at the
end and start over
um and that will also have a bit of
effect of how I consider bass lines
um so yeah and briefly I mean you start
by building something
then you collect data about it's the
measure step
then you derive some learnings from your
data
and at the end you iterate and improve
building and then do the whole thing
again
and let's look into the details
so at the build step
if you are presented with a machine
learning problem or an MLP problem
from my perspective you want to build a
simple model or prototype first like as
simple as possible
I would say
um that should help you get started with
collecting data and testing the
application like if it's actually useful
what you're building like the problem
you're working on is it actually useful
um
and what does that mean for your for
your Baseline
so there are kind of two key things from
this step that your Baseline should
satisfy I hope you can read that in the
back it's a bit smaller the room is a
bit larger than I expected it to be
um yeah so the two things there is like
should do something reasonably like you
should have a patient that does
something it's not completely random or
so otherwise it's not useful
people should be able to play with with
the bass liner with your with the tool
to see something
um and then secondly it should be faster
develop and fast to run like you don't
want to wait for days to see some
results
um optimally you can run it on your
laptop put it in some API quickly that
should all be easy
um yeah so the next step
with a measure step
this is the step where you collect data
and evaluate the performance of your
Baseline
and this step is particularly important
because this also step where you set up
um evaluation pipelines and think about
like how do you measure the things and
how does it fit into the broader system
your company or your project or your
team is building
um and again how does that um affect how
you think about the Baseline
so in this step you also want people to
be able to play with it so you want to
put it out you want to find users that
do something with it or stakeholders get
involved because that helps your
understanding
and you want to get feedback as early as
possible because like most reasons I
have seen data science or machine
learning projects fail is because you
there's no real match between what
you're building and what actually is
needed
and that you want to figure that out as
early as possible and grade your
streamlined these kind of libraries are
great for that to get something out
quickly that people can touch and play
with even with low
Tech experience
cool and now we come to the learn step
um at this step you want to understand
the metrics or the business metrics
better you want to get an understanding
of what is actually required for a
solution like how the metrics you might
pick for example for your classification
algorithm are the symmetric is it is for
a false positive small problematic than
false negative stuff like this one you
want to figure it out there
you probably want to acquire some of the
main knowledge there yourself like that
you know what the systems actually are
putting and can make some reasonable
decision about the quality of that
output
and you want to learn about the issues
in the data and the general problem
setting like understanding what could go
wrong what is probably wrong in the data
collection in the data preparation
in the application of the system
that's what you want to learn there and
how does it affect your Baseline
so the Baseline here should under help
you to understand the problem better so
if possible it should be no black box
solution but it should rather give you
quite specific information about what is
going on between the output and the
input of your system
so that you can understand something
about a problem better
and probably you can use that later for
some get some weed labels we talk about
that briefly later
um and after that you go back to the
table basically and repeat the whole
process of building measuring and
learning to continuously improve the
system
um
they can collect of course more data
receive feedback or more feedback and
refine the performance
yeah
so that's the general framework and the
Aya and what does it mean to the
Baseline at this point
um it should help you like it one
essential piece of a baseline or like
property of a base and it should help
you to keep track of your improvements
right so that you can make educated
decisions in the future
um so you want to compare all further
developed models or systems to your
Baseline to see like is it is it useful
to have something more sophisticated at
the cost of that sophistication right if
you have like I don't know 90 of a
baseline is it worth it to deploy like a
crazy system for 95 and there are a lot
of cases where it's worth it and a lot
of cases where it's not
um so like
get this relations straight
and dash that should help and then also
like measure of course like how how much
you can improve over time compared to
the Baseline
um so you want to put a like a flag in
the ground basically to see like this is
the minimum thing I get when I'm just
thinking about it for an hour or so and
builds up or like for a day probably but
not like for for a month
um
yeah so that's a general framework and a
general idea of what I think is a good
Baseline especially in the area of NLP
um
and let's let's look at some product
example
time really good
um
so let's say so I picked a topic where
all of you are kind of domain experts
right so we want to build
a software a web where we have a web
platform based on recipes and we want to
add some or we are asked to add some
machine learning features there and I
mean you're all kind of have an opinion
about food and about
um yeah recipes probably
um so that's helpful for imagination but
in general this might not be the case so
you might have to acquire some more
domain knowledge
um
so so now we're presented like the
website we want people put up some
recipes and we are asked to do some
things and so the first thing we are
asked to do is basically tag recipes in
three categories based on vegan
vegetarian or with meat okay
relatively simple
so we have our domain knowledge and we
think about it and think like what what
can we do and then we remember
it it might be all keywords right like
and I would say this is a general thing
in a lot of NLP applications or in a
reasonable amount of NLP applications a
lot of the semantic meaning of a text
comes from the semantic meaning of very
little keywords and of course there are
other cases but it's important like a
lot of performance can be
kind of
um
achieved by using keyword-based approach
and here we would just go and collect
some some text some words that represent
meat like we would correct pork and
whatever and I would collect cheese in
the vegetarian keyword list and then you
would just check if it's in the text
right in your recipe so something like
this is probably a bit small now but it
will just check and that can be improved
of course but that's a really really
simple thing you can cover come up with
this in like 10 minutes
depending on how much time you spend on
the lists that are not shown here
um and that actually might give you a
reasonable performance
it's also really simple task but it has
to show some quite interesting benefits
or like properties for example it's
really really easy to understand to
communicate to shareholders and also to
people who for example would label data
later you can exactly say like hey look
we have a baseline that said that why
does it say that because of this keyword
present for example which which might be
um might be might be a huge benefit
but that's really simple it's a bit
boring but there are use cases out there
where people used
Transformers for this kind of things
um so think about keywords first
but just do something a little bit more
sophisticated it's again the
classification task
but now we want to want to judge how
hard the recipe is to to cook like we
want to add it in difficulty categories
basically like easy Advance or hard and
now you think about like how how would
you do that like sure I mean one safe
approach could be you just pipe it all
to chatgpt and that's like give me back
something but that would you would learn
nothing right
it and for recipes you can make sense of
it but in general it might be hard so
what would we do
we could think about like what what
makes a recipe hard to cook it's
probably again something related to the
presence of certain keywords right like
could be like them how many tools
cooking tools are are present in the
text are used
how many
ingredients are used might be a proxy
and how many cooking rated verbs are
there that probably describe different
steps of the preparation process and I
mean you could just again create keyword
list and build rules based off the
presence of these words
you could start with really simple rules
that put some really stupid Simple Rules
there or just count and say like oh if
there are over 15 of these keywords then
you say it's hard if under five it's
easy and if it's
in between it's Advanced whatever that
means
and of course you can tune that kind of
on some data by looking at it and play
with it and see if that makes sense and
you can come up with more complicated or
complex rules to some extent
and then you probably want to move to
machine Learning System but again like
here you could say like if you set up a
labeling tool now you could show people
who label the data like this the opinion
of the Baseline and this is the reason
because we found like I don't know there
were five tools involved
and like 20 ingredients that's the like
that might be complicated recipe or like
a heart recipe but people can have a
different opinion and you can learn from
that
um
so
yeah so keywords keywords are nice
and now
so now quick quick introduction to
weekend transfer learning that's
basically what you can do if you got the
Baseline set up
um
so
it's really brief that transfer learning
basically means you leveraged models
trained on a lot of different data that
are just around and you leverage these
models to learn something faster about
your specific problem which is quite
popular right now with large language
models and fine-tuning them
and then there's like weak learning well
with all kind at the same time
um
which is basically short for learning
with weak supervision for example from
Rules or from like proxy labels you can
get somewhere
um
and it basically is built around this
concept of a labeling function that
input takes the inputs and produces some
label
and you can kind of build multiples of
these label functions based on rules and
put them together with tools for example
like snorkel where they have like
they've tried to figure out a smart way
to combine labeling functions to get
kind of probabilistic labels to improve
um performance of the fine tuning later
or
um
stuff like that or the labeling process
the manual labeling process
which you can do now with these kind of
Baseline where you really have simple
functions that you
understand well
um
and you could also Split For example the
functions you saw before in multiple
functions and use them as different
label function labeling functions
to
to to leverage snorkel for example
better but what you also can do is like
you can just train the system with the
weak labels to actually just take this
little bird right like a large
Transformer model
give it the weekly label data train it
and then mix in later in the training
process you mix in hand labeled or
manually labeled data or corrected
labeled data and that it might learn but
probably will learn much faster
um
with the help of this weak signal you
get
um yeah so and now at this point I want
to briefly go through some other NLP
like tasks and brief say like what might
be a good Baseline there or the idea for
Baseline
in the same same way like before like an
identity recognition or generally it's
like sequence sequence tagging
um if you have labeled data you can just
use the dictionary approach basically
take your label keywords or take the
things you know you want use them as a
dictionary and
test the performance on some test data
which at like basically say everything I
know about people if you want to
identify people take a list of people
check how well it performs on your test
data set which gives you like a baseline
number of how good everything that you
build afterwards should be
um
and then of course if you have some
specific things where there's no General
data available
um like for example if you want
ingredients might be a bit
questionable but like rules on the parse
tree that you could for example get from
Spacey or context words might also work
well as a starting point for a baseline
like for example if you want to identify
persons like keywords like Mr in front
of some token might might provide some
insight about the next word
um
then
then the common thing nowadays that a
lot of people are quite interesting in
it's like text similarity
um
for example in our use case like if we
say like show me similar recipes to the
recipe I'm looking at right now and a
lot of people just jump to the sentence
Transformer thing now but what you all
actually can do is like TF IDF of back
of Words which is basically just also
keyword weighted keywords based approach
I would say
um
which can of course also be used for
topic modeling and clustering and then
from my perspective if you if you
implemented that it's really easy to
like just switch out the text embedding
method like tfidf back of words gives
you a vector for every text sentences
formal gives you a vector for every text
both uh comparing these representations
by cosine similarity so you can just
replace them in your in your pipeline if
you figure out your need
some more semantically
um it's a more semantic capturing
methods in your pipeline or you can go
the other route like and use something I
would call like restricted bag of words
where you say like oh I care about
specific
properties of my
similarity for example I care about is
it similar with regards to tools used
or with regards to whatever ingredients
used so you could say like okay I just
restrict my bag of products vocabulary
to something and then I get you get a
restricted
um similarity
and of course you can balance these both
approaches so that you can say like oh I
take the course and similarity from
sentence Transformers and add it up with
the similarity from the restricted bag
of words and then I can you can balance
kind of how much weight you want to put
on some things and you can play with
that in some kind of gradual fronted for
example to see what fits your need
and then lastly
search
so people thought about search for quite
a while and there's no like
they're quite strong baselines out of
that in practice are super hard to beat
like on type document retrieval or so
like bm25 like the common retrieval
function in for example elasticsearch is
super hard to beat in a lot of cases
sure there are always different
situations but
this is usually a strong bass line and
for prototyping specifically I like this
Luna Pi which is basically a small
implementation of something like
elasticsearch in a way or something like
the retrieval function in lunar a Luna
and in solar
um which is really nice for prototyping
um well so so quick quick summary and
too long didn't listen or too confusing
didn't listening so the main point you
should have taken from this brief talk
is like you should try to start simple
like don't jump to large language models
that's the first thing if you have no
strong evidence that this is the thing
you should try first like try to come up
with something simpler
um then the next thing is build
baselines where you can learn from like
what is it worth
if you cannot learn from the system like
sure if it performs perfectly well on
the first try
then you're fine and you don't have to
learn anything but if it if it doesn't
perform well then you're just screwed
and you have to go back spend a lot of
time probably need to build a baseline
then
um and that's most likely to happen and
then I mean I said it multiple times but
like I would say don't jump on the Deep
learning
approach too early and that might be
reasons again to do that early but often
it's not the case
so so that's the talk
thank you and small ad block so yeah you
can find me on the website I'm a
freelancer to be a sharepoint.com I have
a Blog depends on the definition where
I'll do NLP and machine learning and
stuff
um there's Twitter and there's Macedon
So yeah thank you
and then
[Applause]
and I have another ad block quickly
really quickly so I'm working with some
with some German non-profits where I'm
also co-founder where we try to prevent
discrimination fraught by algorithm
systems and we work with public sector
and companies so if you're interested in
like kind of ethic layer and fairness
you can talk to me and we're also
developing right now it's not public yet
but it's like buyer slides which is a
NLP bias detection toolkit basically if
you're interested in that development
also uh talk to me please
um cool yeah so now
some questions thank you Thomas very
much uh very interesting
um I've checked the slider there are no
questions but maybe some of you has some
or everyone's happy
anything anybody here was the first one
uh thank you for your talk
um I had one question as a general
question one abstract one and that is is
it really like I believe there are some
really good bass lines for various
amount of topics and I wanted to ask you
if you think there is so like if there's
a really still a big market for you know
developing baselines and you have to to
kind of have a yes so is there kind of
it's still a need for developing many
bass lines
hmm so so I'm not so I'm not 100 sure if
I got the first part like what
like why the good baselines for all
kinds of things like I mean they're sure
there's some kind of standard
applications that you could consider in
a way soft right you would not build and
you for like to assist them to get like
person names from newspaper articles you
would not build that yourself you would
just use Spacey or whatever and player
or whatever pre-trained thing but there
are a lot of things where it's now
a lot of applications that fall
in some category of
of tasks like classification or
similarity retrieval or something but
it's not there's no
um there's no one working with similar
data like for example there's a lot of
like really short query search things
with for really specific databases or
like document collections
where there's no nothing is Baseline for
example
so that I mean there are some tasks that
can be considered solved to some extent
and then there are a lot of like
changes on different data sets and
different applications of these tasks to
other day so yeah I mean I would say
there is a need for
baselines of course I say that
okay
let's do one question from Slider uh
there's a question about do you have any
python Frameworks to recommend to for
creating Baseline
I mean
um so I mean if you can for NLP build on
top of keywords for example then I would
not recommend any framework and just
code something up quickly if you can but
of course a good Baseline for NLP I
would say for a lot of tasks is
something built around logistic
regression or bag of words Vector
representations which you can get from
scikitlearn for example
um
yeah
yeah okay just answer the question
hey there first of all thanks for the
talk
um secondly I wanted to ask
especially when it comes therapy often
data is from my experience one of the
most pressing topics because you often
get like things like PDFs or you know
file format in in a non-usable way
do you have any experience in baselining
the data is there do you have any sort
of data collection that you could
recommend for some sort of
um you know creating a quick prototype
or something
so you mean
like pulling data out of PDFs for
example or
so I'm not sure
if I got it
um I mean if you have like the perfect
python package recommendation for that I
would love to hear it
um other than that there are you know
some sort of Open Source databases
um
which some could use for example if you
have the recipe example right there is I
think uh The Taste database or something
that you could leverage to in in order
to create a prototype when the customer
or
whomever does not have the data ready
yet
so I see so I mean sure it depends like
on the use case so in general actually I
have to say I never worked on a customer
use case where it was really
useful
or easy or legal to acquire public data
for that use case I mean there might be
cases where this is the case
[Music]
yeah but it's
it's hard I guess and for PDFs I
recommend PDF plumber if your PDF is not
completely broken which is often the
case and then you're lost but
yeah cool okay I see another question
thank you for that
the talk
um well I have a question because by my
experience sometimes these baselines are
pretty good and by implementing
something very complex the performance
you get doesn't justify the complexity
of maintaining it deploying it but in
reality you are competing for example
you're a freelancer competing with all
the freelance that they're trying to
sell magical Solutions with very complex
solutions to justify their work how
would you deal with that if you know
that in practice probably a baseline is
good enough
good question
um something in general people hire me
to solve their problems
um
and then if the Baseline solves the
problems efficiently well then that's
often enough and also the modeling part
is often not the critic like not the
Super critical part like the critical
part is to measure it properly and
probably sometimes people can also take
over
um and improve the solution right
um I mean I know there is like the feel
of like yeah we but we need a deep
neural network for it because we need to
tell that to management and that happens
yeah but in general in general people
are happy if they get a working solution
however however that is produced
do we have time for one more question
one more minute and we have a simple
question from Slider
um controversial would you consider
using large language models to create a
baseline for NOP tasks
so I mean
I mean I would
I would say like if you consider using
something simple really simple first
like if you think about like could I do
this like if you spend half an hour
thinking about could I do this with some
list of keywords to some extent and it's
like oh it might be super hard to come
up with something
um and I mean sure I mean you can use
like whatever transformer for a baseline
if that if you have data available at
some certain scale like in the in the
correct situation you can do that
um but then you should be able to
justify why why no simple solution at
least like like if I ask you you should
be able to say like well I thought about
for half an hour and probably could have
come up with something but it would have
been complicated and well the situation
is complicated so that's why we picked
this one but like not uh we wanted to
classify recipes into hard and easy and
we've just thrown it to Center
Transformers and hoped something
happened
and then then we worked on it for three
weeks and nothing happened and then
that's not good
sure thank you so that's my opinion
thank you very much Davis please give
another round of applause to our speaker
and
[Applause]